in recent weeks we have heard disturbing
reports of serious failings by police to
tackle the scourge of misogyny and
violent attitudes against women and
girls among the police's own ranks and
Mr W speaker I'd like to put on record
my own thanks to inspector Lee parfitt
and all of the local police and myself
were there who've been an immense
support to me in the recent weeks after
I've spoken out about the horrendous
abuse and behavior of Andrew Tate online
and as a result my own inbox and my
office have been bombarded with death
threats rape threats as a result them
the police have been brilliant but sadly
this isn't the case for everyone who
experiences the same